are you a history major i am i'm a
history and applied math double major
kind of math yes sir what do you want to
do i'm not quite sure well academia is
not lucrative right well i'm not
interested in academia
i farmed and i had three kids and i
lived in the old house and i was making
25 000 and something told me
one day i spoke to a business group and
they said
you're either going to have to write
books or speak or do something because
you're headed toward poverty
wow and that was really shocking to
somebody tell me that in my 30. wow and
he was right so i started writing books
you know there's also because of farming
right you're because someone came in and
wanted to publish your doctoral thesis
right yeah
yeah it was very odd a man named emilio
gaba he's a very famous classicist he
just happened to be in berkeley
and i was farming i had finished my phd
thesis three years earlier and
i got a letter out of the blue he was
the visiting
sather professor was one of the top
professor ships very nice
letter he said we're
from the university of padua and we
would like to publish your thesis and i
was on a tractor when my wife gave me
the letter
and he said you don't have to do
anything
and then they published it and it went
to john keegan and the next thing i knew
he wrote it and liked it and said
if you write another book i will write
the forward wow so i wrote a book called
the western way of war about what it was
like to fight in the ancient world and
the next thing i know he wrote
the forward and it sold very well so
for somebody in their
mid early and mid 30s it was kind of
unusual
because i was trying i farmed for 20
years and then i would get off the
tractor and go in and teach 25 miles
away
sometimes twice a day so it was kind of
a hectic life
i kind of like that though but
the best teachers i've ever had like in
high school or i've always done
something else other than teaching right
yeah you have to but it was very
schizophrenic because
all of the things
that i was supposed to do at the campus
was antithetical to what i was doing for
me and you're supposed to be very
careful what you said and he's very
relaxed
and
you know there were
some pretty wild characters out in
central valley
on farming you know that stealing your
water or wow uh you know other farmers
that would
you know
fight over a road or who had the right
to turn or you're making your turns too
big and then you would it was pretty
blunt and then you go up there it was
kind of such a different change every
day that kind of had to be john wayne a
little bit yeah i wrote a couple of
books about so speaking of books right
you've got one coming out very soon on
citizenship it's called the dying
citizen and you know i'm
an american citizen right i was born and
said i have to do anything special to
kind of get that why is this idea
important well let me ask you are you
shocked that two million people are
scheduled to walk across the southern
border absolutely and without any id no
background check
and the first thing they do is going to
break federal immigration law and it
won't be the second thing they're going
to do is break federal immigration by
residing here illegally and the third is
probably they're going to have id that
is not legal to continue to
and this is all at a time when all of us
are supposed to be vaccinated right
or we're looking at pictures of people
landing and ice we all support
legitimate refugees coming but
they are arriving in bases without any
requirement as foreign nationals to be
vaccinated by troops who have a deadline
that they have to be vaccinated
and so
or where i live we have school board
elections now where people who are not
us citizens can vote
or
we all of the traditional privileges of
citizenship
only citizens could leave the united
states at will with a passport that no
longer apply
citizens usually were the people who
were eligible for state services that no
longer applies citizens alone could hold
office that is still there
it's the only one i can think of that
that distinguishes you and i from right
a resident whether legal or not they can
vote in some cases
serving the military
so
i was curious about all this
and i tried to find out why that was
historically and what was so good about
citizenship because i would bump in
where i live most of the people i bumped
into out in rural fresno county were not
citizens
i had no idea whether they were legal or
illegal residents it was chaotic they
were cast
as it were and i didn't have a
commonality with them because they just
came across the border right
and then when you look at classical
texts the first thing you see is a
middle class they're not is they're not
envious of the rich and they're not
dependent on government as the poor are
and they're not always cajoling that
they're as a rich are to get quid pro
quo concessions
aristotle talks about the messi and yet
if you look at middle class income
college tuition debt
credit card debt
the middle class is beleaguered
especially under globalization the
people interior of the country they
didn't have the skills it could be
internationalized right
and what was weird about it is it has
repercussions the date people are
getting married has gone from about 23
to 29 the first child
is from about 24 to 20 31
the date when people buy their first
home so we're creating a prolonged
like you use the term pajama boy
or life of julia those commercials we
saw during obamacare prolonged
adolescence
and then i also noticed in this organic
process it was almost like the
migrations of the late empire people
were just coming and going
and there wasn't a sacred space
a familiar landscape where people had a
chance to
reiterate their customs their traditions
their familiarity with citizens and yet
that had been a hallmark of classical
greek and roman citizenship to the point
people went to war if their borders were
impaired and say in greece
we've lost that element then the big
bane of citizenship was always a
pre-civilizational
pre-modern
tribalism so you and i have nothing in
common as u.s citizens only a
superficial say we look alike and we're
going to identify first with our racial
or ethnic tribe in other words race is
essential not incidental to who we are
and that leads nowhere
but to rwanda or iraq or the former
yugoslavia and yet that's what we're
doing right now we're regressing
back to 1840 1850 and we're all in this
woke movement
and then i the second half of the book
really quickly is that there's an elite
concentrated effort to dismantle
citizenship
and we you can see it with
the rejection of the word equality which
means a quality of opportunity
replaced by equity and quality result
government is going to redistribute
distribute
income and advantage
often by race and gender so what what
are they doing how do they they
facilitate that
agenda
one thing is we have a permanent
administrative state we always have
started really
during the depression with the new deal
and the great society but now about 45
percent of americans 40 percent work for
the state local or federal government
then we have evolutionaries you probably
have seen these or you know them
academics
lawyers activists
and they don't like the constitution
that's a big issue here at hillsdale
so what do they want to do they want to
evolve beyond it so we're going to get
rid of 180 year
filibuster not in the constitution but
it's it's a custom and tradition
the electoral college is 233 this year's
junk it
the idea that a state like michigan or
california sets their own voting laws
even for national elections unless the
federal government wants to come in for
women's right you know suffrage or 18
year old vote but we're going to try to
jump that 150 year old nine person
supreme court
60 year old 50 states in the union i
could go on but when the system doesn't
work for the progressive mindset then
either change the demography or change
the rules or change the whole
constitutional apparatus by which we
make laws and elect officials and then
finally in the book i have a danger that
i i'm really worried about and that's
globalization
it's an ancient idea of cosmopolitanism
which is a greek word for citizen of the
world
but a lot of our elites on our
bi-coastal leagues feel that whether
it's the davos great reset
project or the international criminal
court or u.n commission on human rights
should
should trump u.s sovereignty they feel
we're sort of an anomaly we're weird
people that have right second amendment
or abortion laws
banning abortion types of abortion
we need to get with it and you can see
that when anthony blinken our current
secretary of state says that the u.n
should come in and investigate us for i
could go on but i that that's a very
dangerous idea globalization was
wonderful in giving western consumer
products medicines
all over the world but the idea that you
would take the next step
and harmonize
uh political norms and institutions
outside the united states that are far
inferior is really dangerous right and i
think there is some sort of like a
perhaps a loathing i guess of american
exceptionalism or something there's a
desire to change things where do you
think that comes from
well barack obama you remember went to
he had said on two occasions i believe
were sex exceptional like the greeks of
the british in other words everybody
believes there are but he made no effort
to quantify that in a dispassionate
empirical fashion do other countries
have due process do they have habeas
corpus do they have a free market do
they have rights of inheritance
do they have a rational system of
adjudicating natural phenomena or
scientific inquiry do they have gender
equity do they have minority
no
most of the 198 nations in the world do
not but this hatred of america i think
it comes some
it comes from
to be quite frank from envy and jealousy
because this country
only has 330 million people
it's not nearly as big as china either
area-wise or population has 14.4 billion
why is it so powerful
why does it have the largest economy why
does one u.s worker at this late date in
american history still produce 40
percent more goods and services
than three of his chinese counterparts
and when they look at popular culture
why are
american music america all over the
world i think you know just
stop it you guys
so they they never make the next step
and say
well maybe we should have a bill of
rights or maybe we should have a free
market economy or maybe we shouldn't
have government so large in our life
sort of like a regression to the mean
right instead of rising up they're gonna
just bring us down as sort of the idea
i think
aristotle and hesia and tocqueville all
of these fallop
they all
postulate that envy and jealousy are the
most powerful of emotions and
they can be very destructive i think
he's he had said there's a good envy and
that makes you see that guy over there
and said
he's got a mercedes this is the american
attitude you go over there and you say
to him how did you get that mercedes he
said well you know i sold real estate
wow i want to be that
the british or the
especially the continental european
attitude or most places is i'm going to
go kick the door in on that guy he must
have done something wrong and i i'm a
better person and i don't have them
right and that's what we're that's why
we're in a crisis now with a woke
movement because that's one of its
tenants
that the system is unfair it always was
1776 is not our founding day
it was always racist it was always
classes
and we need a complete year zero
recalibration
because i'm taking a class and we were
discussing uh the fall of rome and i
think since rome is sort of the the
model i suppose for citizenship that we
adopted and everything i found also
interesting rome citizenship was not
like birthright citizenship like it is
here there was an
essay by a french scholar that
postulated 240 causes to the fall of
rome
whether it was inflation or too much
military spending or too little or
christian a given christianity that
destroyed the marshall
audacity of the legion whatever it was
but one of the
i think one of the more
pertinent or compelling reasons was
as it expanded from a republic
to a mediterranean empire to a global
empire pretty soon
tribalization regionalization and the
system broke down and that's what's very
scary now because we're seeing it in a
variety of manifestations we're having a
red and blue state people are
self-selecting
geographically and we're not having this
idea of the melting pot it's been
rejected
in favor of the salad bowl and now the
woke bowl
that says you have to be racist to stop
racism it's an absurd idea and the idea
that
we're going to check our dna to find
ethnic feeders
look how
ridiculous it becomes ward churchill is
a native american elizabeth warren with
hike cheapo and rachel dolezal is just
suddenly black sean king is as white as
i am and
it's almost the reverse pattern of jim
crow when i was a young kid you would
hear stories of african americans who
were subject to enormous racism
and they were mixed heritage and they
would pat they would say pass for white
now we have people that are passing
and that to tell us something that the
system then
is not racially blind
and it's what professor kendy says that
it's okay to be racist
to
rectify prior racism but the problem is
we've got
more 150 years from slavery and we're 50
years 60 years into affirmative action
and we've forgotten martin luther king's
content of our character rather than the
color of our skin so we've got a whole
generation
that grew up in an affluent leisure to
america a multi-racial america but we're
somehow looking at the white middle
class of the interior of the country
and we're creating all these terms for
them you know
joe biden's chumps drags obama's
clingers
and i guess it's just a mechanism as we
said earlier that you don't want to be
around people of a different class
class is something that's mobile and
fluid you and i are in the upper middle
middle class tomorrow we screw up we
could be our children don't make it they
can be poor
and so that was a dilemma for marx when
he looked at
states or nations that had a fluid upper
middle upward mobility
marxism never worked here but once you
calibrate race into the equation
you say
i postulate that everybody who is
non-white we're going to get rid of the
old black white binary we were working
on the legacy of jim crow or slavery but
now we're going to create a new word
this is mostly barack obama it's called
diversity
and guess what you can be a punjabi
immigrant and farm ten thousand acres
but you are not white you're diverse you
can be an argentine aristocrat
and you can be blue eyed and blondier
but if you have a spanish-sounding name
and trill your name and your name's tony
and you call yourself antonio
then you are diverse
and that can lead to careerist
advantages and it's a new binary but
it's completely divorced from class
the idea of the civil rights movement
where african americans had
discriminated been discriminated so long
and so perniciously that it affected
their economic opportunity that was what
the eoc was the economic
office of economic opportunity it's not
that angry
lebron is a victim
barack obama is a victim
anybody's a victim if they can claim
that they have some uh meritorious
diverse background this is why it was
very ironic for me as i taught mostly
minority students my life my whole
teaching life at california state fresno
and my message was greek latin french
german literature history archaeology
art and your identity is
irrelevant and we're just going to make
you write
and speak english better than people on
the east coast and prep schools that's
what i would tell and i think we
succeeded we sent about 50 kids to the
ivy league professional schools classics
or law or medicine
but some of the students that i followed
it's very funny
they have re-tribalized in other words
somebody have i had if his name was
joe he's jose
if his name was lopez it's now lopez
and they are even though they don't
speak
spanish they're re-tribalizing because
they feel that the woke movement
will either if they don't they will be
deemed inauthentic and suffer
career-wise or if they do they will be
rewarded commiserately and that's really
dangerous historically
when you see that's what hitler did the
idea that even if you speak german
and even if you live in germany and even
if you follow german law you're not
really fully german because we're going
to identify you by the blood and soil
of
pseudo-aryanism and it was one tribe
then
identifying in a way that transcended
shared nation
and we're starting to see that now it's
really scary
what is the positive i try not to be a
negative person it's very easy to be a
negative person um what's sort of the
positive takeaway like if you look at
this country uh what are sort of the
positive aspects you get when i was 19 i
lived in greece and i lived there two
and a half years and went all over the
middle east i have been to every country
in the middle east except iran
and i look at the world south america
asia and here we're sitting in this
student union
it's immaculate
our coffee is not polluted
there's nobody listening there's no
device that i know of
there's a freedom of expression
and we take that for granted but it's
very rare
and that's one thing and then when you
try to look at that personal experience
that we all share that people are not
fighting or blowing up things or they're
not dragging women off and putting them
in a burqa
why is that why are we prosperous why
are we free we have this constitutional
system of 232 years it solved the
problem how to
divide
judicial
executive
and legislative power and checks and
balances and term limits for the
president and so we have the greatest
threat to to any constitutional system
is the absorption of power we've stopped
that
and the result is and we have a free
market we have too much government too
much taxes we've talked about but we
still are the freest place in the world
and we're the only multi-racial
democracy that's ever worked everybody
says well the united states is racist
nobody ever tries it brazil's the only
one i know it doesn't work very well
india can't do it they've got all of
these cast systems and hatreds
most countries are uniracial if you and
i decide tomorrow i want to be japanese
let's go to japan they'll never fully
accept this because we don't live
japanese ditto china ditto mexico
diddle tanzania but this country has
redefined america not in the image of
the original settlers from europe but as
an idea that's a very rare and powerful
document if we get to the specifics
as a classical historian or military
history i always say to myself what
makes a society powerful how do they
project power beyond
and i don't mean just military cultural
or political or social
there's only about six things one is
fuel transportation in the horse say do
they have met uh big planes where horses
can graze or they have wagons or
do they have early steam engines in our
case we're the largest producer of gas
and oil in the world i know that joe
biden's cut three million barrels off
but we still are
if you look at food
in terms of actual dollar amount we're
the greatest producer of food in the
world and we're by far the most
productive china is going to have
trouble feeding itself not the united
states will never have problems feeding
itself
if you look at education if you look at
say the times
educational supplement or
surveys that come out of japan not
americans and they look at the top 20 or
the top 30 universities and they and
they don't do it in terms of their
english department or their gender
studies these studies are calibrated on
their medical schools
their law schools their business schools
are engineering especially math computer
science
the united states usually
rates about 17 out of 20 or 28 out of 30
and it's it's just predictable when you
read them
caltech
mit stanford
harvard yale
and then these big universities michigan
or university of texas or ucla and
that's pretty much all of the
universities in the world
so even for all of our criticism of
education education were there and then
so you got food you got few if you look
at military
i'm a big critic of the 800 billion
dollars it's bloated i think our
generals and admirals have become woke
but our military is the most powerful
military in the history of the
civilization
and you can calibrate that by any
quality a number of planes or
aircraft carrier task forces or
submarine
lethality so it's just remarkable
and so when you
look at all and as i said earlier we
produce we have the largest economy in
the world and when you count calibrate
that economy to the number of people
actually living in the country it's
pretty amazing it's three
two or three times more productive than
china per person
in goods and services so we have all the
ingredients
and history says to us
our problem is not
we're not going to eat we're not going
to defend ourselves we can't educate we
do it so well that we don't even think
of it we're on autopilot and we don't
replenish it i think all we have to do
is like we did during the great
depression or on the eve of world war ii
get serious
and say you know we're coasting we're on
the fumes we've got to recalibrate
ourselves to what citizenship is and
we'll be fine
we're going through a cultural
revolution right now not like mouths but
something that could be dangerous and
yet it's really because all of us are so
affluent and leisured and blessed
and it's not out of death or poverty we
should remember that a lot of
civilizations
decline or they vanish
not from barbarians over the horizon or
they starve to death
but because people no longer believe
they're better than the alternative
or they believe you have to be perfect
to be good
and americans just got to get back to
the the basic idea
we never made claims that were perfect
but we're better than the alternative
and that's good enough
so i really like that a lot actually i
like that idea so what are some you're
talking to like you know student you
know 20 something years old right what
are practical kind of if you know if you
were to lay out you know dr hansen's
game plan for somebody like what are
practical steps that every 20 year old
about 21 year old but practical steps
every person can take to sort of like
make a difference or you know i think
the problem we have with 20 year olds is
they have been sold a bill of goods that
have to be cosmically moral
or cosmically politically correct or
cosmically cosmically woke
and they neglect things that are the
ingredients of a successful and
productive citizenship
so every 20 year old should say to
themselves am i self-sufficient
am i polite to people do i follow the
rules of civility am
am i fair to people
do i judge people on the content of
their character
and then they have to say
am i autonomous as much as a 20 year old
can be i do not want to be dependent on
people i want to be productive i want to
be the people the person people come to
for advice i do not want to go to other
people for subsistence
that was the idea that
jefferson
and what topville saw that what made
america work with her the yeoman farmer
and they combined their mind with their
body and they were not a dependent class
and even tocqueville even talks about
prolonged adolescence you don't want to
live in your parents basement
at some point you've got to say
i'm going to be a citizen and that
citizen requires that most not all we're
not demanding everybody but most
citizens are going to marry they're
going to have children they're going to
buy a home they're going to be
self-sufficient and a very early age a
person say that's my trajectory
and it's kind of a attitude of do no
harm
but if you do the opposite
if your own life is a mess
and you're not able to take care of
yourself but you're judging people
all the way across the world or you're
living in palo alto and you're saying i
can't stand those people in mississippi
that you've never seen
then you're cosmically woke but you're
personally a liability
and so that i think is the biggest
problem that i have when i see young
people because i teach at i'm a fellow
at stanford university i don't teach
anymore
there but i do interact with a lot of
students and they have this mis
this misguided notion that if they have
a high test score
or they lived in the right zip code or
they drive the right car
then that gives them sort of an
exemption from
concrete reality
and they don't have any balance so if
you say to an ivy league kid who is
the epitome of what would you do if the
lights went out right do you know how to
change a circuit breaker you know how to
use a chainsaw these are all skills if
the average american was excelled at
when george patton raced through
europe from august 1st to september 5th
let's say of 1944 in the third army
people were curious how did he do it
the occupied french who were being
liberated the british even other
americans he said it's very simple
american kids grow up fixing things
when our shermans break down we don't
send the transmission back to the
factory it's not fine-tuned by some
german technician
we get the kids that worked on their
model a's they love taking things apart
that sherman is fixers they're crawling
over and they're go go go and then when
we hit the hedgerows they want to make
rhinos they they adapt so what he was
basically saying is that that generation
that came out of the depression
was very versatile and they were very
imaginative and they were very
mechanical and we've lost that i think
we've got to go back to the idea there's
going to be a lot of people in this
country
who don't need to go to college they can
get a liberal arts education on youtube
they can get it on the internet
but they can be well compensated
with
vocational skills there's nothing more
impressive to me than a master cement
person or electrician or a plumber and
when i call i try to do my own plumbing
but when i
get out fox by ancient pipes under 140
and i call a guy in it's like watching a
maestro at an orchestra and he's
rewarded far better than most of the
professors i know and what is wrong with
what he's doing right so i know that in
the 30s and 20s and 40s we got the idea
of upward mobility va but i think in the
new postmodern 21st century it's going
to be let's forget the titles and the
alphabet soup that follows your name and
look at what you can actually do right
and i think that that's exciting is that
it yes sir i think so
that was good nick thank you thank you
nice to meet you
[Music]
you